und auch für dieses wochenende sind
natürlich wieder sogenannte hygiene
demos angekündigt frage ist das wirklich
die gefürchtete zweite wutbürger welle
ein neues woodstock quasi oder letztlich
nur eine laute minderheit die zu viel
aufmerksamkeit kriegt fakt ist da
demonstrieren natürlich auch menschen
aus der mitte der gesellschaft mit der
berechtigten existenzsorgen
wir werden jetzt leider immer in einen
topf geworfen mit den typen die einfach
nur ihr altes merkel muss weg schild aus
dem keller holen
diesmal wie in corona aber selbst von
denen kommen ja manchmal frische neue
ideen
dieser weg mit diesen von richard buck
wir wollen unser kaiser zurück der volt
zurück auf ehrlichkeit auf
menschlichkeit werden nicht mehr wer
wäre denn dann wäre herr friedrich von
preußen
ach so ja das könnte man machen ich
dachte er meint roland kaiser ich sage
mal so freunde
wer jetzt auf diesen corona dem muss ja
schon wieder ständig vom merkel regime
faselt und damit eine demokratisch
gewählte regierung meint er hat sich
lange vor corona von unserem politischen
system verabschiedet das ist wohl so ja
aber den hörst du im prinzip wieder
diesen ja üblichen mix aus eliten
verachtung und wir sind das volk das
sich jetzt gefälligst mal erheben muss
es tut mir so wie meiner seele vielen
jahren kämpft schon für diese ganzen
seit jahren für lügen gekämpft
willkommen beim zdf
sowas könnte politik denn konkret machen
konkret machen damit sich in der
kommenden wirtschaftskrise nicht noch
mehr leute unverstanden oder abgehängt
fühlen was könnte man machen bitte der
lufthansa 9 milliarden geben ja auch von
mir aus mein vorschlag wäre allerdings
erstmal verschuldeten kommunen helfen
ganz genau unseren klammen kommunen
viele hatten schon vor corona probleme
aber jetzt wird es richtig bitter
gewerbesteuer einnahmen brechen den
brutal weg das ladensterben in unseren
innenstädten wird gnadenlos beschleunigt
ganze ketten ziehen sich zurück karstadt
kaufhof schließt bis zu 80 filialen
durch den lock down hat der einzelhandel
milliarden umsatz verloren und aktuell
befürchtet man rund 50.000 neue
insolvenz kurz gesagt die lage ist
tatsächlich so deprimierend das kaufhaus
des westens in berlin wird jetzt schon
umbenannt in kaufhaus des ostens an dem
punkt sind wir unsere städte veröden sie
verwöhnen und mir tun die kinder so leid
unsere kinder die diesen ja flirrenden
zauber nie mehr erleben werden denn nur
eine deutsche fußgängerzone verströmt
ist alles geschichte
willkommen im freilichtmuseum
recklinghäuser fußgängerzone einkaufen
wie einst boomer und opa in sogenannten
läden wo man tatsächlich persönlich
reingeht verrückt kaufen sie doch mal
ein gedrucktes buch wie im mittelalter
bezahlt mit bargeld und nehmen sie es
dann direkt mit nach hause
versandkostenfrei es klingt aber an
alldem verdient jeff bezos keinen cent
unser freilichtmuseum ist immer voll
über 2000 arbeitslose schauspieler vom
bankrotten stadttheater sorgen für
authentische stimmung
das freilichtmuseum recklinghäuser
fußgängerzone kein spaß für groß und
klein
wir haben sogar einen echten panflöten
spieler
[Musik]
ja es klingt lustig ist es aber gar
nicht
viele kommunen hatten gerade angefangen
ihren investitionsstau abzubauen
jetzt muss wegen corona schon wieder
gespart werden bei infrastruktur
freibädern kultur weniger
steuereinnahmen dafür viel mehr hartz
vier ausgaben und ich weiß jetzt heißt
es wieder ja verschuldete städte
die haben halt über ihre verhältnisse
gelebt haben doch umgebracht meistens
eben nicht beispiel oberhausen wir haben
massiv eingespart haben infrastruktur
zurückgebaut bäder geschlossen
einrichtungen reduziert sportanlagen
zurückgebaut
also wirklich massiv eingespart personal
abgebaut und das jetzt alles für die
katz das ist hart wenn man umsonst
gespart hat hätte oberhausen mal vorher
alles verjuxt in seiner stadt erlebt der
bürger staat wenn man möchte dass ich
noch mehr von diesem staat abwenden dann
muss man nur bei den kommunen sparen
deswegen hat olaf scholz völlig recht
wenn er für die einen schutzschirm
fordert robin scholz der rächer der
bankrotten seine idee gewerbesteuer
verluste werden ausgeglichen erstickende
alt schulden erlassen
die kosten dafür teilen sich bund und
ländern sein vorschlag kommt allerdings
im reicheren süden der republik gar
nicht gut an
markus söder zum beispiel fordert auch
deswegen heute eine achtung obergrenze
für corona helfen und sein
finanzminister sagt wie bayerischen
steuergeldes anderswo entschuldung zu
finanzieren dort so bin ich wirklich
nicht bereit
der bundesfinanzminister hat es ja jetzt
verknüpft mit einer altschuldenregelung
für überschuldete kommunen sowie
kommunen besitzen wir nicht
solche kommune besitzen wir nicht weil
wir sehr reich sind
mit anderen worten mehr gäbe es nichts
die schwaben die angleichung der
lebensverhältnisse steht sogar in
unserem grundgesetz klar streng genommen
sind hier die länder für kommunen
zuständig man könnte auch sagen die
übernehmen die altschulden der bund die
gewerbesteuer aber irgend was müsste
passieren muss passiert oder mal out of
the box gedacht der süden sponsored
wenigstens den traurigen rest von
deutschland
dann wird der kreidefelsen auf rügen zur
werbefläche herzlich willkommen in
mecklenburg vorbei das land brandenburg
ab sofort präsentiert von bmw damit sie
schneller hier durchfahren können oder
das geschlossene freibad in oberhausen
jetzt wieder gefüllt mit seitenbacher
müsli lecker lecker lecker einfach mal
quer denken quer denken denn die kluft
zwischen armen und reichen regionen bei
uns in deutschland wird durch gerona
leider noch größer der einzelhandel ist
zwar zurück sein paar tagen aber weit
entfernt von den umsätzen vor bewohner
und die gastro branche leidet natürlich
schwer unter den abstandsregeln jeder
zweite tisch leer 5 schaufensterpuppen
sorgen ab sofort für ein bisschen
gesellschaft für die wenigen gäste die
da sind beziehungsweise da sein dürfen
der vorteil die puppen sind definitiv
symptomfrei und nicht ansteckend diesen
toten blick sehe ich ständig wenn ich
mit meiner frau essen gehe ja aus
unserer beziehung ist nämlich seit
jahren die luft raus entschuldigen wenn
nur jeder zweite tisch besetzt ist wie
soll man da schwarze zahlen schreiben
wie soll sich das rechnen für die
gastronomen und für die wirte und wie
genau funktioniert da die abstandsregel
kann mir dass der bayerische
wirtschaftsminister bitte mal
verständlich erklären wenn sechs bis
acht leute jeder mit seinem kumpel kommt
dann konnte er sich natürlich jeweils
mit seinem kumpel der seine bezugsperson
ist an einen tisch setzen und mit der
150 abstand sitzt der nächste kumpel mit
seinem kumpel aber die könne nicht 602
an einem tisch sitzen weil ja nicht mal
die ersten 6 und einem tisch sitzen
dürften also immer nur mit einer
bezugsperson oder mit einem
bezugs familie darf ich am tisch sitzen
und zu den anderen ist jeweils 150
abstand zu halten
dieses beispiel ginge nur wenn der tisch
irgendwo 15 meter lang ist und dann im
abstand von 150 immer die pärchen
gegenübersitzen bayern schulsystem
einfach unerreicht seit dieser woche
haben die biergärten in bayern wieder
geöffnet gott sei dank jetzt die
schlechte nachricht einige von denen
haben sowie gastro betriebe in ganz
deutschland ärger mit ihrer versicherung
trotz betriebsschließung police weigern
sich die versicherer den umsatzausfall
der letzten monate zu erstatten wir
schalten wir live nach münchen zu
christian ehring
er ist sprecher des gesamtverbands der
deutschen versicherungswirtschaft und
sitzt in einem biergarten
sie sind aber mutig wieso wir sind somit
den wird er hat ich sag mal wenn ich
nirgendwo mehr hin kann wo meine
versicherung nicht zahlt kann ich mir
nur noch zuhause saufen meine erste
hardcore oder komisch schmeckt so ein
bisschen nach ammoniak und ist auch
merkwürdig war
dort kann schon sein ich verstehe das
problem gar nicht mehr in den meisten
verträgen steht doch eindeutig der satz
der versicherer leistet entschädigung
wenn die zuständige behörde aufgrund des
infektionsschutzgesetzes den
versicherten betrieb schließt punkt
genau das ist doch passiert wenn sie das
ist wieder so deutsch
dass man sich in einer extremsituation
wo alle zusammenhalten müssen dann
einzelne formulierungen klammert schade
ich find's einfach schade so ein vertrag
ist noch nicht in stein gemeißelt das
ist eine absichtserklärung wie ich will
meine frau lieben und ehren bis der tod
uns scheidet da geht doch keiner
ernsthaft davon aus dass sowas eintritt
und katastrophenfall die allianz redet
sich wohl damit raus dass das wort cupid
19 nicht explizit im vertrag drin steht
ich meine wie denn auch bei einer neuen
solche ja es muss aber schon so drin
stehen im vertrag dafür macht man ja
verträge er wir sind ja kompromissbereit
zusammen mit dem bayerischen
wirtschaftsminister haben wir uns
folgendes überlegt statt 100 prozent des
vertraglich vereinbarten tagessatzes
bekommen die wird
zehn bis 15 es hat für uns den enormen
vorteil dass wir viel weniger zahlen
müssen und ja und die wirte sie trinken
jetzt aber nicht extra lange damit sie
ihm eine frage nicht beantworten müssen
oder albern und der aiwanger redet das
auch noch schön behauptet einfach mal 15
prozent plus staatshilfen wären ja
irgendwie die hälfte und verläuft sich
dann in einer sehr merkwürdigen metapher
die versicherungen sind auf die gastro
branche auf die gastronomische und
zugegangen seien jetzt schon also die
haben jetzt schon das halbe hendl traut
fertig am tisch alternative wäre gewesen
wenn ich mich zurücklehnen dass ich sagt
er läuft ist händel irgendwo hinten im
garten frauen die es ein dann hast du
ein ganzes händel über den rechtsanwalt
dazu sich garantiert nicht dass du das
ganze hinter jeweils sehen wirst ich
garantiert er das halbe hendl traut
fertig am tisch und viele wirte werden
jetzt das halbe hendl traut fertig am
tisch nehmen weil sie sagen das habe ich
dann sofort und laufen nicht einem hendl
hinterher
das vielleicht andere bundesländer ihren
vierten empfehlen liebe zuschauer wenn
sie mal irgendwo ein minister sähen der
hinter einem rad fertigen händel hair
and verständigen sie bitte den örtlichen
ihren arzt was war denn daran wie sie
nicht verständlich es ist ein
großartiger kompromiss den wir da
gefunden haben übrigens wer die 15
prozent nimmt verzicht auf alle weiteren
ansprüche
das sehen die meisten juristen aber
völlig anders die raten ihren klärten zu
klagen gute idee dazu empfehle ich
unsere rechtsschutzversicherung gegen
kriminell gierige versicherungen ja da
ist mein essen
entschuldigung ich hatte ein halbes
hingestellt das ja nun einzelnen chicken
wings nach meiner rechnung sind das 15
prozent vom hendl
du arschloch nach meiner auch christian
ehring
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken märz gut los du
scheiße fährt